le général lecointe quitte son poste de
chef d'état major des armées
décision prise en accord avec le
président de la république la rumeur de
son départ circulé depuis quelques
semaines il sera donc effectif après le
14 juillet c'est le général thierry
burkhard chef d'état major de l'armée de
terre qui devrait lui succéder au poste
de chef d'état major des armées et c'est
lui qui devra mettre en oeuvre la fin de
l'opération barkan annoncé le 10 juin
on va écouter l'analyse de dominique
train quand il est ancien général ancien
chef de la mission militaire française à
l'onu et expert en géostratégie le
général lecointe a eu 59 ans au mois de
février 59 ans et dada normal de départ
à la retraite d'un général donc il a
annoncé lui-même il en a discuté avec le
président au mois de novembre en lui
disant qu'il souhaitait partir après
quatre ans de mandat c'est à dire un peu
au mois de juillet et ainsi ne pas faire
coller son mandat avec un mandat
présidentiel pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
confusion entre le serviteur de l'état
nommés et un président élu
la loi de programmation militaire
actuelle augmente mais bien sûr il
faudra poursuivre cet effort il le
souligner il s'agissait de reconstruire
les armes et qui aurait été dans une
situation très difficile si on n'avait
pas engagé 7
cette reconstruction désarmés donc oui
grosse d'efforts depuis quatre ans mais
cet effort doit être poursuivie bien